papa julien je suis très heureux
vraiment que tu sois là le mot ce que je
vais te dire tu me manques beaucoup et
vraiment je vois là j'espère que je me
suis dit la vérité
j'espère que ça va marcher pour toi bien
sûr parce que je te souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur mais j'espère que ça peut être
un échec parce que je règle mon jeu je
te dis la vérité tu reviens demain à une
émission sur ces 8 damien gym direct
[Rires]
je te jure mon julien que je suis
partagé
tu vois je vois sur je sais que c'est
mon pote j'ai tellement envie que ça
cartonne mais j'y pense je ne peux pas
trop un accord il faut réussir quelques
unes et puis en janvier là franchement
je te le 10 septembre prochain
on reprend plus cher inquiète pas c'est
une négociation la taille est que toi tu
es ce que tu es heureux
comment s'est passé comment est on dit
tu vas faire capitale parce que au
départ moi j'étais prête à des compromis
ont discuté de plein de choses on
discutait beaucoup de soirées comme
celle qui re semblait qu'il aura
beaucoup plus régionale idée bien sûr de
choses qui arrivent ça a conduit et
abandonné le nom capitaine est arrivée
sur la terre puisque ils m'ont dit on
est en train a peut-être de on voudrait
relancer faire d'autres choses remette
de l'invité est ce que tu te sont hélas
quand il entendit capitaine j'ai dit oui
j'y vais c'est un challenge très
intéressant mais vraiment voilà ici j'ai
fait quatre en cinq ans j'ai tout donné
on l'a vu je ne regrette pas une seconde
mais là il ya une aventure qui est
fantastique je vais avoir des gens
plateau je vais interviewer je vais
forcer un autre délire ah oui c'est un
autre met ses doigts des limaces et d'un
autre côté avant de faire ça j'ai quand
même fait 17 ans sans aucun sens bien
sûr que c'était quand même tous les
matins la radio je suis dans le même
univers que capitale le même c'est la
même chose
d'un côté d'écouté clients de l'autre
peut-être côté entreprises mais voilà
c'est une très très belle entière et
c'est surtout une marque vraiment gilles
1 je peux pas te laisser dire que que ça
marche pas on regarde les scores je ne
serais ce que dès cet été
voilà ça peut faire plus peut-être on va
essayer bastien il a fait le job
et voilà c'est une cour
grandes marques de chaussures dans mon
entourage quand tu dis capitaine les
gens lisent bien sûr new delhi capitale
c'est capital et e10 paris ils te disent
madrid ce que vous appelez pour danse
avec les stars brigitte n'ont jamais
julien oui on m'avait approché pour ça
aussi je serais d'accord ou non c'est
vrai il vous en privez pas dire il ya
deux saisons trois saisons on m'a pas
dit on m'a dit voilà ce que si on met
ton nom sur la liste c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait intéresser
j'ai dit non ces huit ans une journée
entière mais pourquoi c'était la journée
de repos ce que je les ai retrouvé
quelqu'un qui ont pesé et donc une baffe
ça oui
franchement on n'a pas fermé la tuerie
avec un polio plus elle va présenter ses
parents sur la doxa manger assis tout nu
et le plus dur c'est vrai je ne sois pas
tenu ouais le supermarché parce qu'il a
fallu l acheter des trucs pour l'acadie
quand tu passes dans les surgelés que tu
as l'air froid qui arrive
j'ai joué au tennis mais non à wade
trois vols de nom mais servir conclut
avec la matra courbe a déjà un petit peu
rauque bon d'accord elle t'a dit on va
bien sûr du naturisme franchement j'en
ai jamais fait j'ai fait un petit peu de
topless cet été c'est tout je me suis
arrêté là